tonight you guys Ricky and Patrick you
obviously know each other you work
together on extras that you you didn't
think it was Ricky trying to contact you
it is true yeah I had a friend who was
very good at doing impersonations voices
and I was in my local supermarket down
in Burma Z you know keeping it real and
this voice said ah perfect
it's Ricky Ricky and I said Ricky
Ricky's raised yeah
listen we're doing this show new show
and maybe you've heard it man and he
pitched extras to me and he convinced me
that I was not speaking to my friend the
impersonator he really was Ricky Gervais
now I've never asked you this Ricky but
was that the customary way with which
you approach doctor me yeah every time I
asked every person personally to be in
it did you make sure they were in the
supermarket no I did I thought you're in
a play at the time no I thought I was in
the Berman's a supermarket
was amazing it's still the record for
extras for the most takes two grown men
just giggling just giggling every time
he said knickers or something
how many Jake's I think it was about 45
but it was just it was and it just got
worse and then you see the crew sort of
not laughing anymore and then I just
couldn't do it
it was such a silly scene
[Music]
you